everybody loses and I thought this would
be a very public loss if it could have
been I mean now it's postgame at one and
and one so much more than maybe I even
could have imagined it completely
changed my brand in culture in a way
that has opened up in the last 48 hours
financially the things that have opened
up for me are ridiculous
yeah because here's why because sneakers
are so part of culture right now and you
may be privy to it you may not that's
fine
all this trades on is brand and that has
everybody confused
[Music]
you
[Music]
because voice is gonna be the next thing
you'll see you look back at this so I'm
very good at anticipating what consumers
are gonna do before they do it
and that has been my calling card and
I've built a very large wine business
card RS 2005 when he decided to go
massive on you do yes nobody was
expecting every 2006 I started a YouTube
show that was longer than 10 minute
video and I was one of a handful of
videos on YouTube that even made a video
longer than 10 minutes it was all
pirated content it was all you know yeah
I've just done a lot of things early
having somebody follow me around on film
this is no Tyler I love the house my
family is in the house you know we're
two years were over two years in I'm
I've got a you know I'm not a first
vlogger like a Casey and others but I'm
the first over it's like a vlogging in a
different way and so just always doing
things and because of that having a lot
of things not work Socialcam or or you
know Audio Video Email
is something I tried to do a long time
ago ever you never heard about that and
that nobody ever did you know like
there's and yo Bongo and a lot of
investments that didn't work out alpha
boost and and so you know you make a lot
of mistakes the thing is that when
you're when you're a risk-taker by other
people's point of view I don't think I'm
a risk-taker I'm an immigrant out of it
yeah I take risks I can afford to lose
so you know I'll never be out of
business because I'll never waste my
last million dollars you know if I lose
everything I'll take that and be like
okay got to change my lifestyle a little
bit got to slow down which is fine most
people never have a million you earn a
million dollars let alone have it so I
keep things in perspective I came from
nothing I lived in a studio apartment
probably about the size of this small
room we're in right now and with eight
family members what's weird is I'm not
scared to go back I love when people
debate the ROI of this stuff if you
don't know how to use it the ROI is zero
so first things first if you believe
anything I'm saying there's an
incredible website
spell it out for you it goes by the tune
of goog le it will answer anything that
you're thinking right now that isn't
detailed because I'm giving you the
framework how do I place a facebook ad
to sell a car enter you can spend two
hours and by the way if you own your own
business and you do not spend the 30
hours to educate yourself that on what
I'm talking about
you deserve to deal with the
ramifications of what I'm talking this
is not I'm gonna outsource this I don't
want somebody sitting at Table four
right there and saying you know what he
might be right I'm gonna finally listen
to my niece and I'm gonna let her she's
22 she gets this [ __ ] choosing it's [ __ ]
she uses it to live her life she doesn't
use Instagram to sell [ __ ] cars you
need to be the person that understands
this it's funny I I do a vlog and when I
got off stage Tyler and I were talking
like you think you know the team I felt
that was one of the strongest talks I've
ever given to the car in this spring and
we need to make sure we put out pieces
of this on Facebook and all the stuff I
was talking about I'm about to do to
build awareness and brand I'm just
desperate that somebody in that room or
somebody behind that camera does
something about what I'm talking about I
will be historically correct on these
issues I have no dog in the race if
anybody does do anything I just want
them to because it's gonna happen one of
the things I yes one of the things that
really resonated you know there's kind
of this hesitation that's
kind of naivete a little bit about where
things are headed I guess where do you
think that comes from generally speaking
it's why are we I think humans get
complacent I think a lot of people you
know so a lot of so you've got people
some people or just have losing business
DNA and it's a tough word to use but
like they're pessimists they're they're
complaining they're they're looking for
the negative yeah and in general that's
just one of the reasons so that's a
group the more interesting group and the
one that I'm always because because I
don't think I can turn that person yeah
I've tried for thirty years that doesn't
turn here's who turns the one that
worked really hard for twenty years got
there maybe had a divorce because and it
lost his family like a million reals
things or even better has a good family
my dad has this has a family that loves
him but has real regret that he didn't
go to a single one of my literally games
right and he's just and now he's like
wants to reconcile and like take more
vacations or get more conservative the
problem is if you're still running a
business you're on the playing field you
know sports nobody cares if you're
washed up I always use hockey references
one can't I just need it nobody cried
for Wayne Gretzky that last season that
wasn't the job of the other players
right right that's the bigger one
they've worked hard they've won they
can't they haven't won at a level that
allows them to totally retire and did it
have their probably better off to sell
their business right now because it's
still at its peak value compared to
where we'll be in three years if they
have now chosen to completely disregard
the end it's really that simple man you
know it's people that are not on the
offense either because they've never
been and they got some level of micro
success through sheer well luck
serendipity and a million other things
or or a month's not luck it's you know
they it was there or there the second
one which is super interesting man they
really did it they just don't want to do
it anymore
right but they think they think in
business it's not like sports and I
think it's like sports yeah and if
you're on the field somebody's gonna
knock you the hell out right it's like
you know what I'm gonna start using
boxing
Mike Tyson Joe Louis right Larry Holmes
Muhammad Ali yeah monalee lost Trevor
Berbick in his last fight yeah
it wasn't Trevor Berbick job to let
Muhammad Ali win business is sports if
you have a business somebody's trying to
put you out and they don't care that
you've worked hard for 30 years and that
you're a legend you're still on the play
sell your [ __ ] business retire if you
want to be out but if your that's why
man like I don't want to learn Facebook
like I don't like I don't understand
this I'm not gonna spend ten thousand
dollars on something I don't know I'll
just keep spending it on radio I know
that or if I stop doing radio the
business will decline even more and they
don't realize it's the Ritz it's like
you know it's like being an alcoholic
you don't realize it stop drinking that
fixes it when you're in the alcoholic
mindset it's you can't stop drinking or
it will get worse no no no no and
they're stuck on a drug that doesn't
exist anymore which is bad marketing and
operating a business behavior that
doesn't exist a 20-18 world I want to
make sure you understand it Nintendo was
a playing card company Nintendo started
as a playing card company I started off
as a wine merchant like I get it but I
actually usually think the number one
move when [ __ ] is interesting is to
leverage while you've got it the
building of the other thing with the
assumption that the first thing might
not even be there at all and then taking
it all as upside and then you can get
smart right like so the way to get to
the oranges kind of silly lawnmowers a
little bit closer but what about why
can't you guys start the coolest air
refreshment thing in a car company out
of your little one-stop like why
couldn't somebody here create the ten
dollar premium air refresher you know I
just think of this like I don't know if
people think you know like why not you
could and you'd have pretty much as much
permission to do it as anybody else I'll
go I'll go a different place with you I
think that BMW and Porsche and Mercedes
should be going into other sectors I'll
go the reverse I think if I met Mercedes
on the CEO I would be creating
alexxa Google home Apple home pod
competitor because I permission because
of my brand to be behind engineering and
high quality product I would
why should bran be the biggest racer in
the world like I would buy BMWs Razer so
you know you've got to think about where
you have permission to hedge thanks for
having me it was really nice seeing you
guys yeah I'm good daddy take care of
all right big night for d-roc fab and
[ __ ] up and and so you know we don't
have that much footage hey guys picking
us off right now
Tyler screwed up do you rock you're the
best he didn't put me out in time we're
probably gonna miss this flight let's
see what happens
Tyler babban messed up a flight Chicago
later
I [ __ ] up I didn't have my boarding
class going into the airport and
something happened with my check-in it
looks like Gary's gonna make this flight
but now I have about an hour and a half
until the next plane to Chicago we're in
Chicago Toronto is good some really good
interviews hopefully they'll be able to
chop that up a band missed the flight
and that's the key to the episode
[Music]
you